cheppy is an ecologist who studies the
change in the narwhal population of the
arctic ocean over time she observed that
the population loses 5.6
of its size
every 2.8 months
the population of narwhals can be
modeled by a function n which depends on
the amount of time t in months
when cheppy began the study she observed
that there were 89 000 narwhals in
narwhals in the arctic ocean write a
function that models the population of
narwhals t months since the beginning of
cheppy study like always pause the video
and see if you can do it on your own
before we work through it together
so now let's work through it together
and to get my a sense of what this
function needs to do it's always
valuable to to see to create a table for
some interesting inputs for the function
and seeing and seeing how the function
should behave
so first of all if t is in months and n
of t is in n is the
that models
n is the number of narwhals or gnar
whales so what what when t is equal to
zero what is n of zero
well we know at t equals zero there are
eighty nine thousand narwhals in the
ocean so eighty
nine
thousand and now what's the m what's
another interesting one
well t is in months and we know that we
the population decreases five point six
percent every two point eight months
so let's think about when t is two point
2.8 months
well then the population should have
gone down
5.6 percent
so going down 5.6 percent is the same
thing as retaining what what's what's
one minus 5.6
retaining
94.4
let me be clear 100
if you lose 5.6
you are going to be left with 94.4
percent the 0.6 plus 0.4 gets you to 95
plus another 5 years 200. so this
another way of saying this sentence that
the population loses 5.6 percent of its
size every 2.8 months is to say that the
population is 94
94.4 percent of its size every 2.8
months or shrinks to 94.4 percent of its
original size every or let me let me
phrase this clearly after every 2.8
months the population you can either say
it shrinks 5.6 percent or you could say
it has it's gone from it's 94.4 percent
of the population at the beginning of
those 2.8 months
so after 2.8 months the population
should be eighty nine thousand times
i could write times ninety four point
four percent or i could write times zero
point nine four four
now if we go
if we go another two point eight months
so two times 2.8
i obviously could just write that as i
could write that as 5.6 months but let
me just write this as 2.8 months where
are we going to be we're going to be at
89 000
times
0.944 this is where we were before at
the beginning of this period and we're
going to be 94.4 of that so we're going
to multiply by 94.4 percent again or
0.944
again or we can just say times 0.944
squared
and after three of these periods
well we're going to be times 0.944 again
so it's going to be 89 000
times 0.944
squared times 0.944 which is going to be
0.944 to the third power and i think you
might see what's going on here we have
an exponential function at between every
2.8 months we are multiplying by this
common ratio of 0.944
and so we can write our function n of t
our initial value is 89 000
89 000
times
0.8
to the power of however many of these
2.8 month periods we've gone so far so
if we take the number of months and we
divide by 2.8 that's how many 2.8 month
periods we have got gone and so notice
when t equals zero all of this turns
into one you raise something to the
zeroth power just becomes one you have
89 000. when t is equal to 2.8 this
exponent is one and we're going to
multiply by 0.944 once
when t is 5.6 the exponent is going to
be 2 and we're going to multiply by
0.944 twice and i'm just doing the
values that make the exponent integers
but it's going to work for the ones in
between i encourage you to graph it or
to try those values on a calculator if
you like but there you have it we're
done we have modeled our narwhals so let
me just underline that we're done